aaron cevalle is going to pitch fourth
cleveland he's three and over the 242
earned run average
he's given up three or fewer runs in
each of his first four games this year
nelson cruz batting cleanup for the
first time all season long
17 prior starts all hitting third in the
cleanup spot tonight
no score first inning byron at first two
outs he takes off three two pitches
swinging a fly ball to right
down the line to the corner naylor back
drifting and it's going to be in play
and fair as it bounces off buxton scores
easily cruz is going to third base
and he is going to be in with a standing
triple
so an rbi triple down the right field
line for nelson cruz and the twins take
a one-nothing lead in the opening inning
left-handed hitter alex kiriloff
the twins first-round pick in the draft
five years ago out of plum high school
which is just northeast of pittsburgh
now the 1-2 pitch is swinging a line
drive
into left and deep rosario back that's
over his head and off the wall
cruz scores kirill off into second base
he'll slide and he is going to be
out at second base but the run will
count
so rosario played the bounce perfectly
kirill off a one-two swing
doubles or singles rather to left thrown
out at second base as cruz scores
i don't believe the twins are going to
challenge the call at second base
kierloff is coming
off the field kenta maeda meanwhile had
his streak of games
in which he gave up three runs or fewer
snapped at 14
in a loss in oakland his last timeout
and now two down for jose ramirez who
last night hit his
15th career home run against the twins a
game-tying 8th inning shot just fair
down the right field line that came off
tyler duffy
the pitch and it swung out and hammered
to deep right way out of here
number six for jose ramirez
and the indians down two to one in the
first
goodness gracious hopefully everybody's
okay
in the lower deck and right halfway up
those seats
and that was an incoming missile
franmil reyes has been getting locked in
over the last eight games hitting 355
righty righty matchup two to one twins
bottom of the second
kenta maeda into the wind up
and the pitch and it swung on hit high
hit deep to left way way out of here
oh my three quarters of the way
up the bleachers
that was majestic
452 feet
three quarters of the way up the
bleachers in left field
two down here so jose ramirez hernandez
at second
came tied at two now the two oh
and it's swung on lifted in the air to
left medium deep carol off long run
toward the line
got the ball in the scores luplo
into second standing is ramirez
giroloff who's really a first baseman by
trey
went a long way in left field coming in
and angling toward the line
here is eddie rosario let's see if the
indians can take advantage and make this
a blowout inning
and the one-o pitch a ground ball right
side twins have simmons there on the
first base side of second throws out
rosario
to indiana ostidio tapped back to the
pitcher
in his first trip and into right center
field at base hit
we'll watch to see the 40 year old man
come around third and score the twins
have tied it up
on a base hit from
willian's hosta deal great hitting right
there he got a little cutter or
slider this is a big at bat right now
for garver his confidence
has to be down offensively but now is a
chance to come up big for your team
second and third in a 3-3 game only one
out here in the fourth inning
indians have that infield in here with
second and third
one out and a 1-1 count on garver
ramirez back a little bit at third
here's the pitch swung on it's a chopper
to third ramirez charging gloves throws
home
and perez is there for the tag on
ostadio
so they cut the run down at home plate
advancing to third is
cave aborted first is garber
now the number nine hitter and drilton
simmons
here's savali's 1-1 swung on ground ball
to short jimenez flips to the bag in
time for the force
and the side is retired but the twins
tie it
on the rbi signal off the bat of
williams
ostadio two down nobody on game tied at
three for friend mill reyes
hit a 452 foot home run
to the bleachers and left the ball
landed
high in the bleachers where it was
similar
or maybe even a little bit higher than
the walkway that connects
the garage to progressive field reyes
swings and hits it
deep to left forget about it
another rocket
andreas as his second home run
tonight seven on the year
and the indians have a 4-3
lead now jake bowers one for two a
single
left on left here's the set here's the
pitch
and bauer sends a drive deep right that
goes
cave it is off the wall bowers heading
for
two in the scores naylor head first
slide and a double
jake bowers with a hit and consecutive
at bats now
in the game and the indians now lead it
five to three
now catcher roberto perez perez trying
to chase him home the o2
swung on a missed a 94 mile an hour
fastball their strikeout number 18 on
the year for caleb theobar but damage
done
in the home six two runs and a homer and
a pair of double
two down for the shortstop andrelton
simmons
the pitch swung out of bouncing ball to
short belt high hop handled ximena's
guns it over
heading is over my goodness aaron savali
just 11 pitches to get through the
seventh he's now retired 11 in a row
now you know how badly rosario wants to
do against his former mates
luplow at second ramirez at first two
outs
and the o2 pitch a swing at a pop-up
behind the plate garber should have a
play
on the grass he has room and he's got it
for out number three
but savali now all five starts his pitch
count has surpassed
90. as he faces buxton with a two-run
lead 5-3 in the eighth inning bases
empty
buxton swings and launches high and deep
to left field back it goes deep it goes
and gone
number seven for buxton makes this a
one-run
game it's 5-4 cleveland in the eighth
time of the order here is cesar
hernandez
[Applause]
here it comes he hit him
and it's now 7-4 cleveland and now jose
ramirez
the eighth cleveland hitter this half
inning
two and two alfa luda ramirez
breaking ball got him kiriloff
one for three an rbi single off the wall
in left back in the first when minnesota
led two nothing
here is the 1-1 pitch
swung on drill toward the gap in right
center on the run
sliding catch by naylor the right
fielder here's jake cave twins last hope
now the set now the 02 pitch
swing and a miss wiped them out with a
high heat
ball game james karen check as dominant
as ever